you
there we go there we go there we go d4
gave me the ticker over here there we go
four pawns attack four pawns attack it
is right here no matter what building my
center I should have done something more
aggressive with my bishop they're not
striking at my Center I want to remove
their dark square bishop give him a kick
and let's let's push this pawn is
dropping
maybe Bishop h6 he's the number one
defender number one defender you could
grab here but I get the rook and then f7
stuff pawn push okay I'm gonna go for
this might be sneaky they might miss
climb on the Queen they missed it
I almost missed it actually sneak attack
I'm on the knight back to tournament
land somebody has six Jonathan cm you
need to slow down isn't this the guy um
does he go for my queen this guy for
somebody there's somebody who kind of
goes after my queen early and I don't
know why exactly I captured like I did
trying to fishing-pole me alright let's
go here push my pawns
let's take I'm not sure why did that
pawn push is probably good why is my
bishop not on this diagonal yet is
anybody having to answer that you've
gone far enough
maybe oh that pawn push is happening
let's come here no why'd I go there I'm
an answer let's push I need to break
down the C file can I make that happen I
need to challenge that night now I'm on
the pond as well so f4 is not good I'm
on the pond Knight here I take the
knight
Bishop takes pawn I like my bishop I'm
hittin the rook my queen wants to be
here and my bishop wants to be on g7
let's back up maybe grab a pawn and then
come to f6 No
let's go more direct made threats main
to threat making 1 back to tournament
land 6 6 4 alright h7 s brother is what
I'm looking for
does anybody know where H sevens brother
is uh oh my goodness that was almost you
know what the Adobe Flash
it's almost don't be flashed I'm looking
for H 2's brother h7 all right I don't
want to play h3 so quickly get on this
diagonal push night here let's build up
a bit more let's do it now I'm not sure
why right now is maybe the best time but
I want to get to this square I think I
need to play f5 come over here f5
happening soon take with the pond are
they gonna move the knight the bishop
will be trapped wouldn't it like pac-man
mode right pac-man mode engaged he's
gone far enough though smashing through
all the dark squares regardless of how
black recaptures I'm taking like that
get on these dark squares no leave him
up for bait if I did that pawn takes the
Queens there to defend yeah that was
hope chess that's what you call hope
just yes never ever play hope chess I
hope he takes my rook I mean it wasn't
bad it wasn't one of those well what is
it what do I do now if if this if this
plane doesn't work ok just keep pushing
it straight a little bit I insist I
insist I want to trade let's trade can
we
of an extra piece King position came
here ok let's enter where's the mate I
really need to do that there was a more
efficient way me here now he's look at
how fast he is what a sneaky King get
over here eight seconds just make sure I
get this note stalemate no that's me
back to tournament 12 12 12 10 there's
some heavy hitters I seed I seen up
there
back to tournament quick resigner
sixteen sixteen twelve twelve twelve
have to keep it going
age seven age seven okay could maybe
shut down that Bishop let's build a
center here I'll be able to shut down
the light square Bishop with d5 I don't
want to play my Bishop to d3 I want to
keep my queen the direct side of this
it's taken grab some space on the King
side focus on f6 spin the Knight Queen
d2 Castle there's no Bishop h6 now if
they don't have a dark square Bishop
they're gonna be in trouble I keep the
night in the pen anticipating c5 I want
to take now and maybe take a bunch of
times it actually scares me a bit night
here however no well it's dropping stuff
really okay no that's fine
29 seconds is not fine though let's back
rank is vulnerable but I'm up a piece
threatening to winch and win another one
just drop all the way back I almost mile
slipped that was like close to most
slipping night here I could have just
taken that night let's go here I have a
flight square now the night's still
trapped has to do stuff like no he's not
Knight f6 Bishop d5 getting that rook
and the knight let's just trade down 15
seconds night-night we're gotta get rid
of that tricky Knight add all costs back
up here and just stabilize everything so
I could pre move these bishops control a
lot of squares a lot no faster keep
going quicker sneak attack with the pawn
push
keep pushing it's not gonna be stalemate
it's gonna be mate that's gonna be me
back to turn him in twenty six twenty
six twenty twenty fourteen impeccable
the French defense alright the exchange
on c5 kick came out for that diagonal I
really wanted to put that night in a pin
this pawn is maybe a thorn whoa or is he
okay that LightSquared Bishop oh I think
they're in no no no no no I don't need
um I definitely I definitely don't need
a adobe flash gambit how are we gonna
get rid of that guy huh well it's not
really working out so quickly here it's
not easy to develop their knight a
winning material no no
that night can't develop still I want my
night where a bishop
you're my knight right here it's a
really good square I don't want to trade
so quickly my knight is good maybe right
here let's box some stuff out
it's my night gonna be trapped probably
just take him right Knights very tricky
we'll take that pawn maybe it here very
active I could take I take that gotta
watch out for forks
there's too many Forks too many Forks I
have this what I have is that my trapped
this Knight is trapped he's trapped now
could pick him right up oh that's so
easy yeah he's he's on the loose again
oh no oh no oh I'm in check I got to go
fast right here could take that night no
I just got to do time burners they don't
have any time they're down on time that
was crazy ugly is that even a phrase I
was crazy ugly we were just throwing
pieces everywhere stay away from those
crazy ugly positions I tell you ones
where you move just staring at your
clock okay let me just move my pieces
let me just move my pieces objectively
bad another objectively bad move what a
train wreck
oh man okay let's hang out at this party
what about Knight to c7 alright maybe
still my bishops hit queenside castle
and rook to e1 how they finish
development that's a wonderful question
Bishop takes Knight next
oh what a sneak artist oh I have this
though they would if I took here bishop
here
Queen Queen takes Bishop with check was
there oh they should take it my queen
where's the mate start with this and
then here I should just thrown the rope
in my other rook working it's gotta be
you mate soon now okay there we go back
to turn into lane 52 30 30 Oh less than
20
Jonathan see em okay let's go with this
it's uh it's a positional line and I
want that dark square Bishop mm-hmm I
could take here I almost missed that H -
H - I get too excited I don't know if
that's ever gonna wear off that H juice
square gets me good age to Bill Gates
would be proud
Bill Gates would definitely be proud oh
really
I'm not sure what that means not sure
what anything means that you say I'm not
sure if I don't even know what that even
means okay this is I'm down a bun I'm
down upon here I want to kick that night
very soon how soon you ask and I have an
answer to that
let's get out of pins though I know that
much let's get out of pins my bishop is
also in the line of fire and I remain
down upon no I like my bishop pair you
could go back and forth we could do a
little dance on d6 and b4
all right when a pawns attack 25 seconds
why is my bishop still in the D file I
don't want to take you that pawnees
probably poison stay away from the
poison ponds kick the Queen
well castle and opposite wings we should
be doing what attacking one another's
king it's back up Queen coming to a7
let's go there let's go there hmm
I'm gonna get choked Bishop c5 let's go
back I changed my mind
I changed my mind I changed my mind
false alarm is the knight short on
squares he is he's officially short on
those squares Discovery's 12 seconds I
caught up on time Bishop d5 one day
here's a check here no matter what
killed the night and killed upon I could
have taken the pawn instead I'm gonna
attack my bishop let's come back less
than five for them take out the night
and on the Queen I'm on the Queen light
squares light squares I have a flight
square take here no matter what they're
down on time back to tournament 86 56 oh
man 86 56 56 16 minutes we're about the
halfway point brain Craig alright
alright here we go French land French
land alright I can't grab that pond just
yet maybe I'll do it next I will do it
next it's no longer maybe it's an it's
in his it is happening she's gonna have
to just deal with staying home for a
little bit
oh I could go to b4 pawn push it's hit
twice it needs to move so I'm on the
bishop I'd really like to get a look
would get rid of their LightSquared
Bishop my knight probably needs some
more support let me do this take with
the pawn I need to cover this square and
I am I gonna get smashed up I want to
get rid of the night before he kills me
before he kills me oh why did I do that
that's such a bad move that's such a bad
move oh my god
oh my king needs to run for the hills he
definitely needs to pack up and run
Queen here save the day Queen Queen
trade come on you could do it yes the
Queen's are off the board I could
breathe a sigh of relief let's trade a
little bit more everybody loves to trade
is that a mouse slip why was I not just
moving is my king gonna be able to hunt
down that pond he has passed look at our
time come on Bishop here you've got far
enough I really don't want to move I
mean I want to move here I I have a past
pond how about tag get him going how
they like it oh they don't I mean
they're gonna do that I'm gonna force
position I'm down that pond why did I
just give that up
Oh to draw a back to tournament what a
tight game I'm my king was running for
his life I was lucky to dodge that
bullet oh man
time burners that was the time another
time burner game draw that was a drawing
game okay let's focus on age seven let's
break the pen I changed my mind just
like that
you just got juked who here thought I
was gonna play like Bishop to d3
you just got duped what's that rook
doing and c8 I need to know anticipating
c5 I'll play this d5 Knight here all
right let's watch over this my beep on
kills this night on b6 I'm not worried
about any pawn advance like this I have
a space advantage now and I should
probably jump here although I have a
space advantage I'm giving up I'm
trading pieces which makes life a little
bit easier for team black I should
probably set this oh I could have taken
that I'll do it next yeah
not if they recognize it one move later
let's get in b5 let's go
b5 it is let's take here take here most
likely next unless there's something
sneaky my rook is very active I need to
watch over this square grab that a pond
yeah here we go I have a flight square
though Queen on d5 could be very
annoying
my queen still sticking around here
pressure on c6 now just advance here oh
I have a flight square no I have this
King age too
let's just make sure there's some trades
before there's some battery on my first
rank dropping upon are not anymore
they're defending a six okay I just want
to trade 13 seconds on push pawn push
you do that would be sneaky
are they down on time letting their time
run they're down back to tournament 106
104 94-88 12 minutes remaining
Sergeant Pepper this is the guy you
don't want to play right nobody wants to
play Sergeant Pepper once again and line
I have no idea what it means but
apparently I still I still say those
things okay alright ecigs I would love
to see f4 I love it now that the dark
square bishop is long gone how can I get
that they're gonna go trading stop any
nonsense here what about a rook rook
likes that Square to definitely does I
don't even know what that move does
let's get my bishop on c6 Oh waiting
material Knight check no they were well
aware that one
trades I would take with my night
he needs a reposition through their
light square Bishop about even on time
there's a pin with Knight takes Queen
here my knight needs to work he's doing
terrible things right now some sacrifice
in this squares maybe right around the
corner get out of there
why am I not going here tell me why I
didn't put a piece here yesterday oh how
about this I should have taken and then
played h4 cuz now I don't have as much
pressure on this finally I get to break
down that structure finally 15 seconds
this is mates own where's the scene mate
where is the main what's happening soon
they resigned back to tournament I don't
think I had of me but there's definitely
a lot of problems less than 10 is it
just the guy that goes for the fishing
pole I think the last time we played we
both tried to no that was John Madden
that was John Madden we tried to fish
and pull one another
oh I didn't mean to do that my slipper
well slipper could do that oh my
goodness Bishop takes Knight is awesome
why didn't they do that oh they most
lived I know the feeling I definitely
know the feeling
I most lift myself get out of there get
out discoveries oh I could take here or
that no no no no no I could do this I
thought this and I was gonna lose
material maybe they were still that yes
is the Queen that's exactly what I
needed exactly what I needed
oh they're throwing the farm at me kill
the knight coming to g6 queen here
where's the main there it is back to
chairman 146 there 134 124 were there I
was just talking about John man he's up
there second I think Pedro who um who
votes that he who I just didn't worry if
the timing is everything
timing is everything just trying to say
vote for Pedro who votes for Pedro here
who votes for him okay they sniff that
out and you might want to see my night
on g4 they just it's bad enough when
he's on g4 it's just now it's like okay
now you enough Sanaa
I don't even want to see you get to g4
but he's getting to g3 it's a juicy
juicy square this square right here g3
let's give a check maybe force him do a
square he doesn't like check here check
here and then here it'll give another
check next a lot of fancy checks what
are they really amounting to I really
don't know five burners to be honest
time burner strategy that's all that is
can't feel comfortable I know that much
whoa I could take that night Knight
takes bishop next I was gonna look for
Queen trade I'm on the roof
I'll come all the way back now we'll go
for Queen trade take care
check right here no matter what
maybe not huh dad Adobe Flash gamma is
gonna kill me again I know it I know it
my queen is not getting trapped that's
gonna be Nate though soon rook has there
the cleanest of block and I should take
on f3 if Queen blocks Queen takes f3
would be more accurate
166 154 less than seven minutes MMS
oh okay no they're gonna gain a temple
against my queen let's back up
development quick my pawn structure is
gonna be crushed oh boy we're gonna have
a clean trade yes we are
let's go here I guess I guess guess I
guess yeah this is a wonderful wonderful
pin let's get out of it Knight here is
probably good oh I'm okay with that the
bishop here and I have a secure position
now I mean my knight right here is nuts
my pond right here is not so great
whoa why were you not moving just then
okay Bishop here kill my structure again
let's do this I'm gonna grab that pond
okay I have a past a pawn though oh I
guess I'll do this pawn takes is needed
huh
here push my pawn 20 seconds
get him going I'd like to have I was
gonna play Bishop b6 and then a5 watch
out for those Forks they're just
everywhere they're everywhere I hate
that I hate those Forks rook takes pawn
I'm moving my king I want to I want to
keep the night
man that night is just too dangerous for
my likings ten seconds
rook is active oh boy
there's my pawn but not too fast not too
fast all that could have been dangerous
came here game's not gonna end time
burners yes yes gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme just checks and stuff where the
checks oh no don't get mated what am i
doing you got on time Oh messiness
everywhere 186 180 for less than 5
minutes remain 204 we're gonna get
paired up no I thought we're gonna get
paired up cuz the the time just changed
c6 is garbage in these war zones you got
to be more aggressive I that was the
most lip Sicilian ah okay keep the pin I
need to get up quicker win here
right-click Erwin Queen c7 I'm gonna
grab that pawn they're crazy I should
have taken their night I got the H file
if they take and a repaired structure
still welcome to that I'm gonna keep the
tension the queen is more inconvenience
than my pawn on h7 even so I'll give up
the bishop I want to do this and also
maybe f5 I know what I'm doing I'm on
the same diagonal dark square diagonal
you do know this bishops gonna kill me
pressure here not here not here there's
a fork in two spots
now you they have to take all at the end
of it I could give a check if rook takes
here first I have this back rank stuff
oh but wait um is this two beans too
sneaky Queen takes Queen smother mate
it is working back to tournament hope
just hope chess 224 am i within striking
distance how many points do I have 206
it's doable but
think they're ready to win no no no no I
might have to go for sneaky stuff like
scholars mate my view scholar tactics
watch out h6h for some weird version of
a fishing pole
just take them just take them he's free
I promise I promise all right I have
enough support for this are we gonna
trade is that what's happening soon
queenside castle get the G file
get me the G file can't my king over
here they're gonna do that move maybe
there's a reason - let's come over here
finish that thought why don't you oh man
positions change so quickly don't think
get rid of the night how're we doing
timewise these games are not ending
anytime soon let's trade a little bit
why not right why not trade and then and
then what I'm not sure I got a inch Mike
hang up little by little maybe rich d5
was better cutting off the king let's
come over here keep pressure on
something pawn here I don't know about
that King position if pawn takes get the
King out King position King position
King not King position okay at the end
of this I have efore they're in a pin
here probably no matter what
if King F or I take with the pine okay
this is a1 king upon endgame King here
and then here and then here and then
push how're we doing timewise we're
doing fine 20 seconds plenty are they
gonna resign it'd be nice it'd be nice
play this one out - mate that's what's
gonna happen
clearly they resigned back to term in
244 - 26 one minute remaining I got to
do with cheap trick coming up cheap
trick alert 244 226 here comes the
scholars maid
okay how do you do this college mate you
have to start with uni pond okay let's
try this let's do this we're maybe
closed I'm on I'm on f2 though mine f2
Bishop e3 oh oh I've check was just
Castle it'd probably end up losing
material now my bishops still around
he's definitely still around
what about oh that could there belong
the whistle on this yeah they already
awarded the points second place confetti
ah you know it was he probably ended up
winning and as soon as he couldn't be
caught then they just blew the whistle
yeah 264 as soon as that final game was
registered the whistle got blown look at
how close that was impeccable 264 226
216 so any of these guys could have
caught me right here this would have
been a tie if he won one more but tight
race right there actually right through
to first second and third impeccable
myself hi Gerry John Madden alright very
tight group right there there were well
at least at this point there was a
hundred and five players oh man
alright that was intense
some good games in there
you